good afternoon a father has told sky
news of the
awful moment his wife and son died in
loch lomond
on saturday twenty-nine-year-old adina
olahova her nine-year-old son
rana hariseli and their friend muhammad
asim riaz died after getting into
trouble
in loch lomond one of the largest lakes
in great britain
husband and father varus ellie described
what happened
on tv we just decided to take break
and the kids standing on pier
on the corner
he just dried would fit inside the water
but suddenly deep water was deep
i think too deep and
i think my wife our awesome wife someone
seeing kids he's
drying and drawing in water and we all
run me jump in water
awesome and when we drown in water
and my wife seen and she jumped i think
as well
when i came out after five ten minutes
from the water i bottles send me
shallow side i came out and i think
my wife in the water
i take off my shirt try to give her if
she can catch and when this was too far
i run away on the roads that one guy
doing barbecue or something there about
four or five minutes walk
i call him he can swim
he came and he take out awesome son
ibrahim and after he said i can't bring
other children
i'm joined now by our correspondent
inzamam rasheed
in zamam understandably varus ali deeply
distressed recounting
what was meant to just be a short break
turning into tragedy what else did he
have to tell you
yeah it was a heartbreaking recount of
what
happened on saturday two families had
traveled
last week to the isle of skye to spend a
bit of time in the sunshine to have a
bit
of a holiday on their return to glasgow
they decided to stop
off at the north end of loch lomond
where
they pulled out and they went for a bit
of a dip
in the water they were walking along the
pier
when two of the children put their feet
in the water not realizing how deep it
was and that's
when the trouble started parents saw
that the children
were drowning a seven-year-old and a
nine-year-old
and subsequently the parents going to
try
and save them but unfortunately what
ensued
saturday evening was absolute tragedy
the death of a nine-year-old boy rana
haris
ali the death of his mother
adina alahova 29 years old
and the death of a family friend as well
muhammad asim riaz
who was 41. now the father and the
husband
of rana and adina also tried to help
save lives he managed to survive
managing to kick himself up from the
water getting breath
when possible and then getting to
shallow parts
of the water before a nearby
local came and tried to help save some
of the people he managed to save a
seven-year-old boy
the son of muhammad assam riaz who is
currently
in hospital in a critical condition but
sadly on saturday evening
three people dying in la clement and as
i mentioned
a very emotional interview from waris
ali who was
now mourning the loss of two is his two
of his family members but also
his best friend a best friend he said
that was like
a brother to him just read you some of
the extracts
from that interview he said his wife and
child
were so special they were really happy
people they would help me
or absolutely anyone if anyone was in
pain they would do
whatever to help them and he said that's
why today
his wife is not here because her husband
he
was drowning in the water he went on to
speak about
his son harris saying that he used to
say when he
wanted to grow up and bigger than his
dad that he wouldn't have
to go to work his dad could stay at home
he could look after
his parents like he wanted to become a
policeman or a pilot or a dentist
and he said that i will earn the money
when i grow older
and i'll be bigger than you very shortly
he said he simply didn't have any words
to put together how he felt right now
losing his wife his son and his best
friend
someone who was a brother towards him he
said being in a house that he's in now
doesn't feel like
a home without those family members this
is a snippet
of the interview when i when i spoke to
him a bit earlier about
what exactly happened at the time they
were trying to rescue the boys
who were drowning in loch lomond that
time i
even can't think about anything when i
forget everything just
now i'm reminding of what happened that
time i don't know what was happening
just
i'm calling hell and trying to call for
99 you don't understand location then i
pass home to someone
because my breathing that was not good
as well you know understanding
what i'm saying if one
scottish girl one family came and one
scottish
girl he take over phone from me and he
then explained everything
to emergency services and then
start arriving police
ambulances and after coast guard
what's incredibly heartbreaking here is
that
not just the children who were
struggling but then the parents who went
to try
and save their children also getting
into horrific trouble
in what was in incredibly deep waters
but also
very cold particularly when outside it
was
extremely warm now juarez ali
also telling us that he was notified of
the family's death in hospital
at around one o'clock on sunday morning
and he also noted
a message from nicolas sturgeon the
first minister
tweeting yesterday telling people to
take care
if they go swimming in some of the
world's most beautiful
lakes and rivers and he said that my
message to people
is that they shouldn't go where there
isn't any help
the mistakes that we made i don't want
other people
to do that so also a stark warning from
a man
who is now mourning the loss of his wife
his son
and his best friend in what was a tragic
incident
and loch lomond on saturday evening